the families of victims in the Sandy
Hook school shooting will take their
fight against gun makers to the
Connecticut Supreme Court they want to
reinstate a lawsuit against the
manufacturer of the military style
weapon that was used in the 2012 attack
the families claim the company markets
its weapons to young people who could be
prone to violence Don Dahler is in
Hartford outside the Connecticut Supreme
Court house where today's hearing will
take place Don good morning good morning
last year a judge dismissed the lawsuit
by some family members of Sandy Hook
victims citing a federal law that shield
gun makers from liability in gun
shooting deaths now lawyers are
appealing that decision saying that
Remington knowingly marketed the ar-15
style rifle to a high-risk group of
young men including the shooter Adam
Lanza nearly five years after her
six-year-old son Dylan was killed by
Adam Lanza armed with an ar-15 style
rifle nicole Hockley wants the gun
manufacturer held accountable this is a
weapon that has been designed to inflict
mass casualties and you're not a man if
you don't have it that's that's morally
reprehensible and from a marketing
perspective that's just that's wrong and
needs to stop in a brief submitted to
the Connecticut Supreme Court attorneys
representing ten Sandy Hook families
contend that in order to boost sales gun
manufacturer Remington targeted a
younger demographic by linking the ar-15
to Macho vigilantism and military-style
insurrection in print ads the firearm is
portrayed alongside phrases like perform
under pressure bow down and consider
your man card reissued remington
increases the risk when they market the
weapon this way of pulling in these
dangerous users josh Koskov is the
attorney representing the ten families
not all of them are gonna you know use
them like Adam Lanza but selectively
they're gonna be at increased risk
according to the gun violence Archive
more than 1,500 mass shootings have
taken place since Sandy Hook legal
analysts say appealing the dismissed
lawsuit rests on proving the
manufacturers negligence allowed the
weapon to fall into the wrong hands what
the appellate judges are supposed to do
is judge this case according to the law
so although these are rigged
horrific shootings that have happened
are out there theoretically the judges
should disregard them CBS News reached
out to Remington for comment they have
not yet replied now if the families are
successful in this appeal that opens the
door to the discovery phase in which
they might have access to internal
documents and emails that could reveal
Remington's marketing strategies Gail
still one of the worst heartbreaking
stories ever reported Thank You Don
Dahler